I should I want the hell ride looking
ankle pants actually what is it like to
free the ankle I can't look at a man's
foot though that's the only problem with
me yeah guys would put their feet on I
just can't do it I don't feel like their
toes on my shoulder cuz even because if
your toes they're really pretty then I
was like why why your toes really pretty
man yeah what are you doing why you
gonna pedicure you a foot model dawg
what's up everybody I'm Krista Stefano
welcome to stupid questions this is
James Davis he's got an hour special for
Comedy Central it's gonna be good we're
in Los Angeles
he's from Los Angeles I'm from New York
you know what that means hashtag suck at
Chicago all right question what is
something that's not a holiday but you
think should be a holiday they have
national recycling day national water
day national clouds day what's your day
I think to Fox birthday here you gonna
be a day sure
like Tupac Day September 18th June 16th
is his birthday
yes mine is June 15 that's the way you
know great people they born around the
same time well you know who has my
birthday Macaulay Culkin so right right
great people yeah great winners yeah box
office winner yes okay here we go if you
could make a rule for a day that
everybody had to follow and if they
don't follow they get their heads
chopped off what rule would it be you
know what hey if you hate on somebody
you're done death penalty really for
being a hater yeah no no no no not death
penalty don't you want to bring back
hitting people if I got out of line and
you punch me in the face I would wake up
from consciousness and thank you it's
now I'm a better person I believe that's
a cultural and a local thing because I
know definitely areas where if
somebody's got pleasure right now right
so punching is very active around the
corner ah area okay but however like you
know off Wilshire socking is a little
bit more risque but people get shocked
out here you absolutely
mind your business you'll get hit and
punch in the face by James Davis
here's a stupid question you ever hit
somebody in the face with a golf club
no but I've come close I've been hit by
a golf ball and hit me my pelvis you
know how close that is to get your jewel
I mean that's that's where your jewels
come out of is that it's formed in the
pelvis yeah so God is good thank you for
diverting and I thank you for not
hitting James's dear God
yeah cuz that would have that probably
would have been yeah life-changing
oh I'm Saul you kidding me a hundred
percent life-changing what if it hits
the the sack this well for me it's I got
a kid already so he can take my sack
throw it away I'm done with the sack
I'll dump it all out in here drink it
whatever you need me to do play fill in
the blank finish this finish the
sentence I wouldn't be caught dead blank
stealing jokes you would the area go see
you're you're a good kid never never
steal a joke I look at jokes like
outfits you know you know you don't want
to be rocking with somebody else's
rocking you're good dresser you always
had since day one you've always been a
great dresser fine I'm not a good
dresser for me if I was gonna style you
and you were trying to look your
absolute best yeah I didn't put you in a
tailored suit or you look like some kind
of like
FBI agent okay or I'd put you in a
soccer jersey you got a World Cup top
frame top frame but the lower frame is
brutal don't talk about what they can't
see
yeah that's true man you know I could
just be floating towards oh you know
like there's an eight-pack under this
would people all right here's question
you ever been caught by your mother
masturbating oh I have uh yeah yeah you
have yeah at the time I thought I pulled
it off as far as like you know what you
did not know they know you know what
you're doing it's like weather why are
you just yanking covers to your chest at
the end of stupid questions I like to
give people a stupid gift and I like to
give you a stupid gift now and um you
like golf I do right you big golf guy
that's out there absolutely you also
like toilets so I figured why not get
you some little potty golf look at that
you play golf while you're taking a dump
here you go man thank you this is uh
dude that's something you're gonna use
tell me you're not gonna use that I'm
not gonna use this all right
[Music]